die skeptiker hat nun recht
mobilfunkfrequenzen verursachen krebs
das ist jetzt bei einer studie mit
ratten nachgewiesen worden
aber so einfach ist es denn dann auch
nicht denn die wellen haben auch
positive effekte und das experiment fand
unter ganz besonderen bedingungen statt
also was ist jetzt sache klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
science videos abonniert den kanal dann
verpasst ja keins herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
also was ist jetzt sache also konkretes
ergebnis der studie
wenn männliche ratten achtung jetzt
kommen die bestimmten bedingungen
erstens dauerhaft zweiter mit hohen
dosen
drittens mit bestimmten mobilfunk wellen
bestrahlt werden dann bekommen sie
viertens bestimmte tumore das betrifft
vor allem den herzmuskel und das gehirn
und die frequenzen sind die von umts und
den vorgängern das ist das ergebnis
einer studie im auftrag des nationalen
toxikologie programms der usa damit ist
ein direkter zusammenhang zwischen
mobilfunkstrahlen und krebs nachgewiesen
worden
aber die forschungsgruppe sagt auch ganz
klar dass die studie keine rückschlüsse
auf den menschen zulässt interessant ist
auch dass weibliche raten gar nicht oder
kaum betroffen sind weil menschen gibt
es keine situation in dem es zu
dauerhafter bestrahlung kommt auch die
stärke der bestrahlung ist in den
meisten fällen deutlich geringer bei den
versuchen wurden die ratten vier
unterschiedliche strahlungsintensität
'nen ausgesetzt die schwächste entsprach
dabei der stärke die maximal für den
menschen zugelassen ist alle anderen
stärken kommen beim menschen nicht vor
zudem wurden auch positive auswirkungen
der bestrahlung festgestellt die
lebenserwartung der ratten stieg im
schnitt vermutet wird eine positive
wirkung der wellen gegen nierenversagen
was eine häufige todesursache bei ratten
ist jetzt sollen weitere frequenzen auf
diese weise untersucht werden wie 5g und
wifi und bei der untersuchung
festgestellten mutationen die sollen
auch unter die lupe genommen werden
spannend dass es hier so lange
funkstille gab bzw
immer die unschädlichkeit von mobilfunk
wählen betont wurde
ich bin sehr gespannt was da bei den
weiteren untersuchungen herauskommt wenn
ihr dazu und zu allen anderen themen
wirklich kein video verpassen wollt dann
abonniert auch den englischen kanal
dafür einfach hier klicken
auch da gibt es die ein oder andere
video premiere und darunter hier geht es
weiter mit ice age in europe the dream
come true stencil also einfach
draufklicken und ansonsten csu
stay tuned